[Music]
tonight is the second presidential
debate you excited about that
of course it already well it's happened
when this airs we tape about four months
early so I don't even know who the
candidates are we taped this in late
1998 I'm 11 years old not far off no
second presidential debate is tonight
President Obama is now saying he was too
polite to MIT Romney in their first
debate he said he was too polite yeah to
make up for that tonight Obama plans to
address Romney as douchey J moneybags
[Applause]
[Music]
as you know my real name I am douchey J
moneybags a long line of moneybags one
of President Obama's goals tonight is to
win back female voters yeah yeah which
explains why Obama is going to answer
every question with a passage from Fifty
Shades of Grey
analysts say that to woo female voters
tonight both candidates both candidates
will try to come off as the good husband
yeah
when asked for comment Bill Clinton said
that is the dumbest thing
[Applause]
[Music]
there's no way they're not good ladies
like
your mother say any hereby this
controversy with Paul Ryan oh yes I
stopped by a soup kitchen soup kitchen
yeah yeah well after Paul Ryan stop by
for a photo op at a soup kitchen the
head of the charity said Ryan did
nothing yeah
in other words that man is ready to be
vice president you know who endorsed
Mitt Romney just came out with
endorsement Ross Perot
has endorsed Mitt Romney this could help
Romney with the coveted vote of people
you forgot we're still alive enough
about the campaign all right
legally I have to ask Andy I have a
mission alright go ahead
exciting news from the auto industry
this is cool a company just came out
with a car that will retail for only
three thousand dollars they're calling
this revolutionary vehicle the 1997
Corolla my first car in LA was in 1977
as Suzu Opel oh yeah they stopped making
it because they realized technically
it's not a call right right those ones
you can take apart with your hands yeah
of course you all heard about the Hulk
Hogan sex tape you've seen it you're in
it there's a rumor that Hulk Hogan was
the one who leaked his own sex tape
authorities believe it was either him or
al-qaeda we don't know either way they
sense the crowd thought I was going with
leaked yeah yeah which bums me out some
reason did you think they were highbrow
I don't know I don't know either I just
think maybe we shut it hey check this
out gang
I always do that when it gets a little
quiet sure sure hey gang gather round
for this one
according to a new study Adele's someone
like you is now the most popular song
played at funerals yeah yeah it narrowly
beat out Pink's let's get this party
started
[Applause]
[Music]
I know no one does this anymore
well I get amuses me